>>> TOGHT USG TRUMP'
TRUMT CAMPAI
EVENR
TRUMP'S SECTARY
>>ANS TIME .
D ENERGYND FOCUS TO TE
URKISHLE
ANMEN . NOW,, FORMER
FORMER SENLEMc ASSISTANT
TO GEORGE W. BUS SO SCOTT, ONE
OF TRUMP
REMEMBER, PAINLITICAL
OPNTT AND SSNA
HE DIDTI
EITACTEI USED BY AP  O
ME TA LOT.
THIS GUY'SON
POO TO RUN FOR 24 ICATIONS HERE
THIN ATTACK,TTS, YOU WANT
YOU THINIT FAI  ATCK WHETH
THAN A FORMER ITTES CRETARY O P.
>> YEAH TH IS,NFORTUNATELY, E C.
UM ATTACKING
PEOPLE, AMERICAN.
CONGBA
WHEROM
CETETHIS STYLE
U
MY ONLY SADNE
ONLY W Y ATTACK UMAND HIS CRN TH
IT'S UNFORTUTE>> RIGING THE SAM
YO SCOTTW,ASSOEW
YOORRY
D ASPHE THE
INMETHE DR LABS, THAT D ERS, A E
.
SEEN WHAT OUN W Y.CO IS A SOVER
IS THIS REVELATION GOING TO
HIS LOYALISTS OR OE POT IN
NTTES ENTANYL
COMING OTH. HONEST, IF JOE BIDEL
NOW CELEBRATING HIS BO
N PEOPLE ARERAZYABOUT THIS
WE'VE BEEN USING U.S. MILITARY E
SHOW, SAW AN AA
TODAY,NG DRUG WAR
LATIN AMICN
MILITADRLE IN MIDDLE THIS  DEALS
AND YOU ASKED MECAOPLE LIKE THI
ALREDOEADY, THERE'S
TRUMP'S BASE, BUWH
CRS?AN
WORKED
AITE OKUTTING ALL TS STUF
TH
GUY WAS Y AND FUD I'M W INDONYT
N
BOOK LE
ENCOURAGED
NEVER CAD OING TO COMD SAY HEY
BISAS GOING TO STARTE AND ON TWV
BOMBING XI WOULDBRATE TH
INPEOPLE IR PART
I THINK MITHE IC CRAZY FOR FOUR.
OFOMPEOPLE, OUAKUMP AND MAYBPEO
OFTS
I REMEMBER A CONVEAT
AGO HE TOLD ME HE T THE OILS IN
SAARE IDENT, NOW WE HEARS FROMEI
TODAY  CD  AGAINAND ELD OUT OFA
DE AE IT WAS
ANAME
T
OFT SERIOUEVER KANY ANYOU KNOW,
ASN
TELLOUIGHT N
E E DRUG WAR IS SERIOU
SERIOUS BUSINESS, THE IDEA HTRYG
OPLE WOULD NDO THOWHIT FOLKD HAE
RESPONDED TO THAT AND NOT SURE
THEY THROW IN THEY'LL NEVER KNOW
AMERICAN
UNTRIES TSE BEEN SENDING
NECESSARILY A NEWIS ALLIME.
>> WE'RE PRAISING IR